und ich frage sie direkt was droht in
unserem schulsystem wenn wir weiterhin
so vorgehen
ich denke einfach ist das schulsystem
über aufgestellt wir müssen wissen cola
ist da gucken sie nur ein etwa
zahlenbeispiel es kommen eine normale
schüler etwa 800 schüler 100 kommen aus
risikogebieten zurück wie wir jetzt alle
gelernt davon sind fünf prozent
infiziert also in jeder schule ist jetzt
fünf prozent danke kinder geben nur das
heißt dass die krankheit und von außen
hinein
wir wissen aber andererseits dass bis 12
jahre ist so gut wie noch kein kind um
kind zu kind angesteckt haben also es
wird nicht zu massiven ausbrüche kommen
so wie hier ist wie es von der grippe
kennen es wird isoliert bleiben und ich
denke mit denen die bühne machen die von
dem spanier vorbei eingehalten werden
gucken sie die kinder tragen masken
bisschen abstand zu halten bleiben in
ihrer gruppe um ich persönlich sehe ich
keine gefahr
es muss eine klare vorgabe vom
kultusministerium sein wie man damit
umgeht
ja auch sehr interessante frage in nrw
zb gibt es ja die masken pflicht für
kinder in anderen bundesländern ist das
nicht so warum gibt es da so große
unterschiede in den regelungen was
verstehe ich auch nicht ich denke dass
ich abstand halten und in seiner gruppe
bleiben wenn man das macht wissen was
dazu sind die maßnahmen der da kinder
sind so wenig empfänglich für corona
wären wir selber haben sämtliche gruppen
septischen klassen kindergarten nachhol
wo ein problemfall von außen herein kam
und nie hat es untereinander
ausgebreitet
ich persönlich sehe da gar keine gefahr
so groß natürlich wenn ein kind pro
monat muss es raus genommen werden
müssen was abstand halten maske tragen
in seiner gruppe bleiben wie wichtig ist
für mich die anamnese
man muss herausfinden was sind jetzt in
einem risikogebiet oder haben geehrt
haben große partys gemacht veranstaltung
das ist die gefahr
ich denke darauf müssen wir uns
fokussieren und nicht wahllos jedes kind
mit husten schnupfen zum kinde zum
testen das ist auch gar nicht möglich
wir haben das in letzter zeit gemacht
wir haben 1500 abstriche bei den kindern
gemacht
der ausbruch gefunden dass sich das kind
angesteckt hat also ich sage immer
erschreckend bei kindern bis zwölf jahre
wird von oben natürlich von den eltern
dass das möglich aber ein kind zu kind
horizontal da sehe ich also nur eine
minimale gefahr und mit einem restrisiko
müssen wir leben bist du was wir machen
auch fenster auch in den schulklassen
jetzt was eine sehr vernünftige maßnahme
ist und das risiko ist natürlich dass
man ein kind raus fällt das ist ja auch
schon einmal was wir aber mit restrisiko
im leben müssen sie umgehen
ganz klare worte die sie da finden
deshalb lassen sie uns noch einmal
zusammenfassen was machen ihrer meinung
nach eltern und lehrer falsch ich denke
zu machen wäre nichts wir haben ein
super konzept hygienemaßnahmen die sind
hervorragend werden wie durchgezogen was
ist ist es wären unnütz längste
aufgebaut
wir müssen einfach wissen die krankheit
kann in einer schulklasse form und es
ist inzwischen so verbreitet dass wir
damit leben müssen
aber wir müssen nicht planegger und
gerade zurzeit ist eine sommergrippe in
deutschland also wir sehen masons kinder
hier mit husten schnupfen fieber
sie haben alles nur kein bewohner ohne
haben sie nur wenn herausgestellt sie
kommen aus risikogebieten oder aber es
wurden großen partys hochzeiten gemacht
also wenn du solche familienfeier sind
dann sollte man eben wenn man kinder da
nicht hingehen
die gefahr ist eindeutig von den eltern
und nicht von kind zu welt